all right you're done let's go look at
the solution where we left off last time
as you can see we have two empty queries
for location ID and location these two
queries look a lot like the queries we
have for weather for location ID this
looks almost exactly like what we do for
weather except we use a hard-coded query
rather than relying on the one passed
into the function since we know that
this is always going to be a long
integer value it is easy to just build
the value into the query string location
on the other hand looks almost exactly
like the weather query we just pass all
the parameters into the database
you didn't think you're gonna get away
without testing did you don't worry it's
really easy to add this test it turns
out that calling our function within the
provider works almost exactly the same
as the way we did the weather table all
we have to do is replace weather entry
content URI with location entry dot
content URI and of course we still have
to delete the two columns that we can't
support now that'll actually work let's
test that to make sure that works and
our test passed as expected
the interesting thing about this task is
if it's actually only testing the first
query and it just happens to work
because we deleted the database before
the start you'd be much more interesting
to query for the row that we just
inserted and this will test the other
query now let's run the test again and
those also passed so we have some of our
queries from our content provider
functioning but unfortunately we still
have to do some of the more complicated
things in the provider let's talk about
joins